this
is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where dad is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice ken
coleman
ramsey personality number one
best-selling author host of the ken
coleman show talking about careers
and jobs is my co-host today so if you
want to talk careers and jobs
this is a good time to do it for sure
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight
eight two five five two two five can
your show
on now 75 plus radio stations and sirius
xm and a popular podcast
has become the perfect one-two punch
because ninety percent of my work has
been
on the out go side but there's two sides
of this financial equation the income
side is the other side i don't get to
talk about that enough and you being in
the marketplace
teaching people that uh your income and
doing work
that matters and doing work that with
your life that you care about
um is part of the equation of building
wealth
that's absolutely right it turns out
that when you do something that you're
really good at and that you love
you get promoted more because you are an
attractive candidate an attractive team
member because the leader says wow
you know this person is clearly doing
what they were born to do
we want to give them more stuff to do
you know a happy and an enthused
you're an employer when you see somebody
that's on fire you've talked about this
a lot
you we want to hire those people because
you said you're one of my favorite
davisms and i don't know if it's yours
by the way
but you can't light wet wood in that how
you say it's not a
yeah i stole it but yeah we'll give it
you can't i mean
it's really hard to light wet wood it is
you know i was i'm burned out it's
impossible you're never on fire you know
i mean so
you know it's just you got to get you
know if you're happy notify your face i
mean you ought to be doing something
with your life that you love and that
you're engaged with right and sometimes
if you that means changing from what
you're doing
and um you know you have the seven steps
to getting to
a career yeah uh that that you love
and that you're passionate about and the
first one is get clear the second one's
get qualified
yes and getting qualified can mean uh if
you're gonna open a
lawn care business uh that you uh reach
over and
pull the uh pull the thing on the mower
and get get the
engine started that's qualified um you
get your button gear right
uh but qualified could be getting a phd
could be
uh if you're gonna be um or getting your
md if you wanna be a medical doctor
getting qualified there's only one way
to do that right and that's go through
med school so
you know that that step while people are
working to get out of debt sometimes
throws them it does because they're
sitting there going okay wait a second
i'm gazelle intense i'm trying to get
out of debt and we don't stop that
but what we have to look at is we have
to first determine what does it look
like
to get qualified so we asked the
question what do i need to learn
what do i need to do that's education
and experience how much is that going to
cost me there's a cost of time and then
obviously
if you've got to spend some money to get
qualified and then you say okay based on
those answers i've got a plan here well
i'm getting out of debt and there are
many times where
you must get your financial house in
order walk the baby steps out because
here's the good news
that dream career is still going to be
there the the ability to get qualified
is still going to be there
and many times though we see people can
cash flow their way through it
because a certification may be something
that you can do
it might just be that you don't need any
kind of new education
that you just got to make some
connections and people say you know what
you've got some raw talent
we're willing to train you on the job
we're seeing this with companies as
large as
google where they are doing on-the-job
training so getting a clear picture
about
what what i actually need to get
qualified
then we can go oh it may not cost me as
much as i thought
and people you know that with the epic
student loan crisis and with the
shutting down
of colleges during covid uh universities
during cove
people started to really start to look
at higher education
but too many people still have in their
brain that if i don't have an mba
that's table stakes for me to do what i
want to do and it's
it's just not simply not true it's just
not there's a few things that are table
stakes there are a few things you've got
to put that
chip on the table in order to keep stay
in the game that's in order to get to
the table stay in the game
and but there's very few things that are
real table stakes
but people put that up and it's really
an artificial barrier
it is i've got two questions that i ask
callers
on this show on the ken coleman show to
consider when they say do i need
the next level of education the first
question is is it the only way
so let me give you two examples that
everybody gets if you wanna be a lawyer
you gotta have a law degree you just do
if you wanna be a doctor you gotta have
a med school degree
those are a couple of examples that we
all get so you gotta look at what you
wanna do and you gotta truly do the
research and then you say is this the
only way to get the ticket to the dance
and if it's not then you ask yourself is
it the best way
okay and if it's not the only way or the
best way
wait a second that means there are
multiple ways and let's look at that you
and i've talked about this
the best way could be i can't afford it
that's exactly i've
got to find the other way because this
is the way broke people do it that's
right i'm going to cash flow my way
through it yeah i'm good with that
i've done that most of my life on a
whole bunch of things the best way is
just go buy a brand new one
no but maybe not maybe the uh best way
if you're too broke to do that because
you don't have any money because you've
been buying all the brand new ones right
then maybe you need to buy a used one
before you buy this right and see that's
where the baby steps come in
so the best way for many people is let's
get to baby step
three right let's get there and then
let's go all right
what do we do now can i now because i've
got my emergency fund in place can i
begin the cash flow
getting qualified and here's the other
thing dave
i know there's this there's this desire
in all of our our
humanness to just make progress as much
as we can
but the thing is is that if you walk the
baby steps out then get to the place
where you can cash flow your way to get
qualified
you may take a little longer to get in
that dream gig that you've always wanted
but it's actually going to feel
wonderful you're not going to be in a
nightmare scenario where
we have a lot of dentists or you just
pick the career where they're doing it
but they're underneath a mountain of
debt it's not
worth it if that dream becomes a
nightmare then we interviewed a dentist
in uh the borrowed future podcast yes
that between student loans and buying
the practice had over a million dollars
in debt and he had just
gotten into the practice and his lip is
quivering
absolutely tears running down his face
as he's describing
the crap he'd gotten himself into and so
yeah what we what we've learned to do
over the years at ramsey is to teach you
yes
the ken coleman way to do careers is
there
and yes you can walk the seven clear
steps to getting the career you love and
yes you can do that and it's not
incongruent
with building wealth it's not
incongruent with staying out of debt
it's not incongruent with any of those
things uh as a matter of fact it's
highly congruent
uh absolutely it's actually the best way
to do it tonight
we are doing a live stream event
i assume our studio audience is sold out
we have a small studio audience of a
couple
of two i think we're sold out you know
about 100 coming in yeah it's going
to be able to sneak in here if you ask
somebody at the door real nice
i might walk out and get some people in
you yeah you never know but uh anyway
if you're feeling stuck or you're
disengaged from your current job you
dread getting out of bed going to work
in the morning you're searching for a
new job for any reason
the get hired live stream is tonight
with ken coleman april the 27th
it's for you it's only 30 dollars and
you can text hired to 33
789 and get your tickets text tired
to 33789 i highly recommend
if you have any idea that you might want
to be doing something different
that you watch ken tonight he's going to
walk you very clearly
through exactly what to do you're going
to leave inspired laughing crying
and believing you can win this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
i am dave ramsey your host this is a
show about you america it's about your
life your money your career
your mental health your marriage your
money your life your career your mental
health your marriage it's about you
celeste is with us she's going to start
off this hour
in tucson arizona hi celeste how are you
hi i'm doing well how are you guys
better than i deserve how can we help
that's great um so really quickly to the
point well first of all thank you for
all that to do and
thank you for having me on um so
to the point i am at a very very toxic
work environment right now
um so i'm kind of just what you were
talking about you know i get up and i
don't want to go to work
i get up and i'm i'm dreading going i
hate being there it's
gotten to the point that i just want to
quit and i'm not a quitter
so it's a very difficult time and like
season of my life right now
um however they do pay for school and so
i'm four classes away from getting my
bachelor's however this past i'm
supposed to graduate in may
um and i just you know a lot of things a
series of events just happened and it
didn't happen for me
um i'm now at the point where i'm stuck
at this job until
october 26th there's no transferring for
me there's no
moving up nothing i was initially only
there because they paid for school
but at this point i just i need
something that's going to make me happy
i have the money to pay for my summer
classes
however i'm i'm trying to pay everything
off i finish baby step one and i don't
want to continue
using the money that i'm saving to pay
for school when
i have school paid for if i stay here
but i i
don't know what to do what is the nature
of
the toxicity what's the problem with
this
um i i just i don't grow
i have no growth um that's not
communication
support that's not toxic there's no
support that's not toxic
what's toxic there's no support and
you're not growing you're in a dead-end
job it's boring
whoop-dee-doop-dee that ain't toxic
okay so tell me what tell me what's
toxic is somebody
is there sexual things going on or
people yelling and screaming and cussing
or
is somebody throwing things at you um
are they you know discriminating against
you in some way
i mean what's what's toxic
well no it's not all of that no you're
right but it is
it's no one speaks to me i go and i say
good morning no one talks to me
but that's you know that is me
complaining i should just go and do my
job that's what i'm there for
however there's just no support i can't
i can't
go talk to someone they're not letting
me know they're not asking me hey like
how are you and i don't know if that's
maybe me just complaining but no no i
like to go to a police officer
the job sucks yeah okay i don't i don't
have any doubt i mean you're kind of
like it sounds like office space the
movie you know
yeah celeste first of all dave's asking
the right question we want to get to the
the source of toxicity so that you can
get the right frame of mind
uh but i'm going to tell you right now
you're dealing with something that
happens in offices all across
the country and all across the world and
you're just underappreciated
people want to know am i seen am i
valued and that's not
fun and dave's right it sucks but let's
reframe your perspective all right
let's just go through this very quickly
you're four classes away
from getting the bachelor's which is why
you took the job
so what's the new timeline if you stay
at this company so they pay for the
forecast
is that what i heard october october
26th wasn't it
october 26th okay great so i'd hang in
there until october 26th this is an
attitude change
this is hey i'm grateful for this really
boring place
because this boring place is giving me
the opportunity to step up to the next
rung on the ladder in life
what you're learning here is how never
to lead when you have the opportunity
you have anti-mentors
they're teaching you how not to do crap
yeah and you know but but if they're not
being nasty to you
or breaking the law or you know
asking you to do something that's
immoral or
that kind of stuff uh then it's just a
matter of that they have they
it's a dead-end job it's boring and
they're not the nicest bunch of people
in the world they don't they're not very
friendly if that's the whole version of
toxicity
you stick this out you suck it up and
stick it out
get your mind on the future pay for it
then no i have the money to pay for it i
just
i don't want to because i'm trying to
save my money i'm trying to pay off my
debt
i'm only 11 000. stay on the baby steps
stay stay with what you're doing yes let
them pay for it and finish
it's it's listen it's part you know
you're going to school
and i can guarantee you you've gone to
some classes that are taught by a
tenured professor
who's boring as crud and not a very good
teacher
and that desk hurts by the time you get
out of it
i've sat in those stupid classes
and you're doing you're putting up with
that toxic stuff
in quotes in order to get a degree in
order to further your life
you're delaying the pleasure you're
putting up with some pain to win later
does that make sense
it does i just feel like i'm delaying
the the chance to leave this job if i
were to just pay for if you can leave
the job and someone will give you a job
that pays for your education
that's all thrilling and they affirm you
every day have at it
i'm actually going to push back celeste
i don't think you're delaying your exit
from this boring job
you're del if you leave you're delaying
getting into the next baby step don't
use that money when
they they're gonna pay you how old are
you
i just turned 24. how many brothers and
sisters do you have
i'm an older brother and a younger
brother you're the middle
yes okay
interesting all right i yeah i i still
i um you can do whatever you want you're
a grown person if you want to quit and
spend your money
but basically you are writing a check in
order to get away from these people
that's what you're doing and i i don't
hear anything here that's worth writing
a check for
um you know 68 of americans are
dissatisfied at work is that right
it's absolutely right close to 80 and so
that means that
uh at least half of those are
experiencing something along the lines
of what you
are experiencing because most people
aren't leaders most people are bosses
that's exactly most organizations don't
affirm most organizations don't
communicate most
organizations suck and that's why most
people don't like working there
and so uh but toxic is when something's
happening to you that's abusive
yes and you're not being abused kiddo
yeah you're just not being affirmed and
it's dead end and it's boring
yeah you gotta change your mindset here
it's wait a second i'm
grateful for the money
to get out of to to get the schooling i
need while i'm getting out of
debt it needs to be a total shift we
know this from nurses
i worked in a place in my 20s one time
that everybody
in the building it seemed like right was
sleeping with each other
oh it was a dad gum soap opera yeah yeah
that's a nice way of saying it yeah
um and it was just nuts i mean and i'm
in the middle of this thing and i'm
going this is
gross yeah and you know what i was only
there for about five months before i got
moved on right
and and but it was one of my first few
jobs coming out of college and you go
through some
situations like that but you know what i
learned from that you know that that was
30 something years ago i'm sitting here
talking about it
what i learned from that is i'm not
going to tolerate a situation like that
but and i'm not going to now that i'm in
a position to control it i'm going to
have a whole bunch of people inside our
building
that are running around like it's some
kind of orgy or something yeah this is
nuts
and so people do this though in the
workplace and but not ours and you know
not there
and we're not you know it's not who we
are and so then a young lady or young
man could come to work here of character
and they can feel safe
where you know that and now that's toxic
yes but but you know but i still i i
didn't
walk out the door and quit that day i
endured
it for a while but what i got from the
endurance was the lesson
to make sure it never happens in my
environment quick thing here folks we
see what we focus on
we know this they've done all types of
neuroscience studies on this when you
buy a car
you get excited about that car purchase
how many of you see it everywhere
for the first six seven days it's
because there's an intense focus on it
when you focus on being a victim
you will see victimization
everywhere you go as opposed to going
wait a second
i'm so close to being debt free and my
school paid for with a degree
and all i got to do is put up with
boring awful leadership until october
i can do that yeah that's you gotta wait
until christmas to open your gifts too
i hate that dave i do no discipline
seems pleasant at the time but it yields
a harvest of righteousness
this is the ramsay show
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more
[Music]
[Music]
verses
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this is the ramsey show open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five landon is with us in
memphis hi landon
welcome to the ramsay show hey i
appreciate you taking my call
sure man what's up so i'm 24
my wife is 22 and we'll have our house
paid off in five minutes
yeah and yeah i appreciate it
but um so after we pay off our house we
want to save up and pay cash for
rental real estate and i was just
curious on your opinion on if we should
and i grew up in real estate my parents
didn't real estate so i was just curious
on your opinion on if
we should maybe just kind of start out
by doing a couple of small flips or if
we should just kind of go straight into
real estate you know rental real estate
and i
just kind of wanted your opinion on that
well flips are real when you're doing
them with cash you can make money
right uh and with your background in it
i i
if i woke up in your shoes i would do
some flips i've
used to that's how i used to make a
living when i was your age
and so uh i was so stupid i did it with
debt back then but um
uh you know now
um you know here's the trick okay
and you already know this but i need to
say it out loud to make sure all of
america hears it
uh people doing flips off of what they
see on an infomercial or reading some
kind of stupid book
uh lose their butts in the real world
on a flip you are gonna look at 200
properties to buy one
right because you got to steal it
there's no margin
if you're paying 80 of value you're
going to break even
right minus repairs so our
our formula when we were doing flips was
70 of value minus
minus repairs and so um
you know if the property was a hundred
thousand dollar property for easy math
that means i'm gonna pay 70 if there's
ten thousand dollars worth of repairs
i'm gonna pay 60.
and it takes a while to get at that oh
by the way you're in a ridiculously hot
real estate market where any stupid
thing that comes on the market sells
instantly
and so you're gonna have a hard time
finding deals right now
sure i i suspect memphis is the same way
as the rest of the nation i don't know
but there's about an hour outside of
memphis and so it the market's
not quite as crazy as memphis is and so
you know it's a little bit easier but
it's you know it's still you know
the white hot market yeah but the bottom
line is
you make your money on the buy if you're
doing flips or if you're doing long-term
investing either one you make your money
on the buy
meaning you're going to get a deal or
you don't buy it and
that means you cannot get emotional you
cannot get
fever like ooh ooh there's money's
burned a whole pocket i got to buy
something i got to buy something i got
to buy something
the first property i ever flipped i was
22 i made 832
i barely got out because i was an
idiot and i paid way too much for it i
bought a hud foreclosure
and i thought because it said
foreclosure that meant bargain it
doesn't the number means bargain
not the situation yeah yeah yes sir
and so if you if you'll stick to the
math and put some business practices in
place
that guarantee profit and you'll do some
flips with cash
it's also probably going to be very hard
in this current situation
but i love the concept and i made a lot
of money doing it
uh but it's uh it's most people don't
have the patience or the diligence to
look through enough deals to get a real
deal
and uh and they get emotional and they
get oh i've got a
i'm a real estate investor now and then
they just go
buy something and they do something
stupid yeah i love that formula the 70
of market than the expenses itself and
then i don't know if this young man can
do it but if you've got the skills like
my father-in-law
he's got the skills his contractor he
can go in and do
save a lot of on that actual expense
budget too you know where some people
are getting crushed by
here's the thing you don't want to
uh you want to budget it out as if you
paid a contractor because if you're
going to do the work
you ought to get paid profit on the deal
and you ought to get paid for being a
contractor
i love that if you're going to be in
there swinging a hammer don't do it free
that's right
you're going to be on a business end of
a paint brush be paid be paid
painters wages and make your profit too
yeah
that's a great forum yeah you don't want
to say oh i'm going to pay them
more for this house because i don't have
the level of expense that means you got
paid zero for your labor
great great point there you don't want
to do that so
but i made the decision i can swing a
hammer i can fix anything but i made the
decision
even at 22 that i was going to run
cruise to do it
uh because i my highest and best use was
not on the business end of a painting
brush it was getting the next deal
and um you know hunting the next deal i
make more money hunting the next deal
and i did paint houses
yep otherwise i'd just be painting
houses see that's a great point too so
know what you do best
what do you do best for you well where's
the you know the highest and best you
should you know what's your best return
on the doll
on the time spent dollar return on the
time spent how much per hour are you
making looking for deals how much per
hour you making painting houses
and that that's the difference and
that's what you get into so you gotta
it is nice to be able to do the stuff
and that way when the crew leaves in the
middle of the job you can jump in there
and finish it out because you had you
hired
some bozo to do the work um not that
that's ever happened to me
but um anyway no emotion on that
sentence
at all no sarcasm dripping off of the
tongue
jake is in boise idaho hi jake how are
you
good dave thanks dave and ken for taking
my call sure how can i help
so yeah our question is uh have a
promotion opportunity that's causing us
to
move from eastern idaho over to boise
we stand to make about 140 000 in the
cell of our home
and we're wondering if we should take
that 140 000 and
put it into our new home or if we should
pay off our debt and live with the
in-laws for a year
and then buy home after that how much
debt have you got
we've got about 80 000 uh 35 in
student loans why couldn't you put 60
down on cars
you could uh we've got uh five of us
my wife and i and three kids and so a
home in boise would feel like we're not
gonna get
quite the home we want with sixty
thousand down
okay and you're gonna be making what'd
you say
so currently making 90 the promotion
expect to make about
140. okay the difference in eastern
idaho and the white hot boise real
estate market
is not 50 and your income is going up
50 percent so
you should be able to move into a the
similar home to what you have now
in square footage but it's going to cost
more with your increased income with a
60 000
down payment now right
you can move in with your in-laws if you
want i wouldn't
that'd drive me nuts in them too um
but i mean you got 60 000 put down on a
house you're debt-free
you have no payments in the world uh and
you live there two or three years and
maybe you move
okay or you rent for a year rent for a
year
and put your 60 000 in the bank right
and but i mean you can move into them if
you want if that just if that's good for
you but um
there's very few families in
uh i mean there are there are in
different cultures called families that
come from different cultures do it all
the time but
um you know i i come from the noble
hillbilly culture
and uh we don't do well moving back home
right right no that makes sense so i
mean it's just there's too much
it thanksgiving dinner is a good that's
a good thing it's a little distance
there
we can leave after the turkey's sliced
uh but i mean some people can do it and
it's okay
i'm not saying you get you know that
they're bad people or anything like that
you're just like a grown guy making 150
grand moving your mother-in-law's
basement feels weird
yeah i you know i i agree with you but i
will say the other side of that coin is
if he can do it and he really weighs
this thing out where are we living
what's it look like how weird is that
gonna be can i bite my lip
what kind of relationship does he have i
get it i'm i'm in the same boat
but listen stacy's parents are saints
but if you moved in with them they kill
you
well that's yeah you're right same as me
that mouth it wouldn't last i mean it
works good on talk radio it doesn't work
good at the dinner table
i'm with you dave i'm just trying to go
man that is nice if you got that
you can pack a lot of money away i love
my father-in-law i couldn't live with
him 20 minutes
yeah because he it wouldn't be fair to
him
i'm not that easy to live with yeah so
i mean y'all just you got to decide this
stuff and i think sometimes when people
ask this question they're only thinking
about math and they haven't thought
about the emotional and relational
strain
i'm going to agree with you on that
jake's nicer than you and me it sounds
like
it sounds like the math is gonna make it
all okay
the math goes away quick not so much i
get it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality
is my co-host today ken is the host of
the ken coleman show
which airs on 75 plus radio stations on
siriusxm and is a podcast youtube show
as well
so you can listen to it as a podcast you
can listen to it on youtube
and it's all about discovering your
purpose it is all about
you living in the dream meaning doing
work you love and getting paid
a lot for doing it you do not have to
take a dumbed down
income in order to find work that has
meaning
that's a false dichotomy it's not true
and ken is here to walk you through that
as a matter of fact tomorrow no not
tomorrow night tonight
yes on the stage here at ramsey the big
spotlights are out here like it's
hollywood or something we're getting
ready to do this
live stream with ken tonight and he's
going to cover the seven steps to
get hired it's the get hired event
tonight the 27th of april
and we want you to tune in tonight it's
um tickets are just
30 and you can text the word hired to
33789 and uh that will come on live at
7 00 p.m 7 p.m central 8 eastern yeah 7
central 8
eastern so uh and tonight you're gonna
be covering the eight steps and other
things as well going to be diving really
deep on the first three stages of get
clear get
qualified get connected the seven stages
to
doing what you were born to do we're
going to dive in because those are the
three stages that allow you
to get noticed and get hired and
i actually got something for you dave
because we'll unpack the seven stages
really quick we just mentioned the first
three
because i've got i want you to weigh in
on stage five for our audience
so get clear is figuring out talent
that's what you do best
passion work you love to do and then
what are the results that's the mission
that you want to put out in the
workplace then you got to get qualified
that's stage two stage three get
connected all about relationships that's
all about your number one best-selling
book the problem
the right people in the right places
give us opportunities so that puts us at
stage four where now
we got the gig and we're starting we're
on that ladder
stage five is get promoted and that's
a stage that we stay in for a while as
we keep getting promoted
keep climbing the ladder if you will
until we step into that dream job and
here's the thing
that i want you to weigh in on because
you have great insight on this
saw an article yesterday dave that the
oldest millennial
okay in the workplace will turn 40 this
year okay according to those who
determine what's a millennial or not
so the oldest millennials turn 40. and
for the first time
we see that there are just as many
people in leadership
or management positions under the age of
45 dave as there are
that are over the age of 45. and so this
article was talking about how these
millennials are now as they get promoted
as we see anybody get promoted
at some point you're going to be in
leadership
you hear it as management we call it
leadership here and so
dave it's just inevitable as i get
promoted i'm going to have opportunities
to lead and they were saying a lot of
these millennials didn't set out to
become leaders
we teach a lot about leadership here you
learned to lead you started out in real
estate
started a radio show as your
organization grew people come in
and you were learning to lead and thus
you created this term that became a
bestselling book
entree leadership i i thought it'd be
good for you to kind of explain that as
you're going to get promoted you're
going to have the opportunity to lead
people i think a lot of people are
scared
i've never led before i can't lead and
and i think and you believe that
leadership can be learned it can be
developed what do you say to those
people who are going i want to get
promoted i want to keep doing it but i
don't know about this leadership thing
leadership is one of the hardest
endeavors you'll ever undertake but it's
not complicated
great statement so you shouldn't fear it
um because it's not like it's like
uh becoming wealthy there are no secrets
to the rich so like for instance when we
start some of the lessons in entre
leadership one of the lessons i start i
ask people what are the character
qualities of a great leader
and most everyone will tell you about
the same thing
yeah i've seen you do it they all pop
out the answers you know they use
sometimes they use a little bit of a
different word but
there's only about five or six things
that pop up every time they're a servant
they're humble
they have integrity they have vision
they have energy
and passion um they're affirming
uh the things like that are what we
always hear that's what you think of
when you think of a leader now not
necessarily a boss
if you want to be a boss that's a
different thing but if you want to be a
leader
you've got to be in front you can't be
behind
bosses are behind with the whip driving
cattle
yes leaders are out front casting a
vision and saying this is where we're
going
if you want to go the train is leaving
in just a moment hear the whistle
you need to be on the print train this
is where we're going
and if you don't get on the train you're
going to be left at the station
and so leaders sometimes leave people
behind that don't want to go
won't keep up sometimes we ask people
off the bus
as my friend jim collins says because
they shouldn't have been on there they
don't fit in with a vision they don't
they're they're
a toxic uh you know problem inside the
organization they don't have the skills
to bring it
uh whatever and so we have to walk with
them but if you will just
love people and serve them
and not try to be a boss and
think about okay if i'm gonna lead
say name the person doing that job
just switch roles for a second treat
other people like you won't be treated
so how would you want someone to do that
you'd want them to occasionally smile
you want to say
hey you did a good job at that that was
good it's a good job
you'd want to be told when you're doing
something doofus so you don't do it
again because you don't want to be a
perpetual doofus that's not good for
anybody
uh you know what would you want people
to do if you were being lit and that
it's really not complicated but it's
hard because
people some people are crazy yeah the
best thing about leadership is people
yeah
but the worst is people exactly about
two percent of the public should be
institutionalized so um
you know and some of them will come to
work for you god help you you know
and and they they they dress up nice so
you make the mistake of hiring them
but then they get in the building and
you got problems and then you get other
people who surprise you the other way
that you thought well i don't know if
that's going to amount to much but he
turns out to be dead gum albert einstein
you know and um actually that was
churchill's
grade school teacher sent him a note to
his mother said this one's not going to
amount to much
winston freaking churchill you know and
so you know but
sometimes you have that you get the
surprise right obviously that grade
school teacher was a bit surprised if he
lived long enough
um but the um
uh to see the man that almost
single-handedly saved the free world
oh you know an unbelievable act
of leadership uh and so a series of acts
of leadership but again it's not
it's not really complicated it's just
hard
because you are subordinating uh your
own
rights you're putting other people
forward and you're putting the mission
ahead of your own rights it's not
the leader who wants to be in charge in
order to be in charge
is never going to make it no the leader
who wants to be in charge because if we
go
yeah i'll get this done together we're
going to get it done right we're going
to get it done faster and a bunch of
people are going to be helped on the
other side
mission critical mission first driven by
the task
driven by the desired future and we're
all on the page to that and anybody's
not on page to that we're going to help
you get on the page or get you somewhere
else
that's leading yeah jim collins our
friend that you mentioned earlier he
calls that a level five leader based on
the research and basically his one
sentence description of those level five
leaders is
is that it if we win
we all win like so if you win we win if
we
win in this team the whole company wins
so if this particular division wins here
the whole company wins if the customer
wins
we win it is as you said mission above
everything else
and that's really huge and dave to what
you said about it not being
complex the research shows that men and
women would rather get
public recognition or some type of
reward reward
recognition more than a raise and that
speaks to what you're talking about and
they don't care if the leader is perfect
no all they care is is that they're that
that they are that they're just telling
the truth
yes do they care about me yeah do they
care about me and telling the truth you
know like going through covid you know i
told everybody
we run out of money we're all going home
because i'm not borrowing money to prop
up payroll
i told everybody that yeah and let me
tell you what happens here's what how
much cash we got and here's where we're
going to be
and when the cash runs out leadership's
all going to go to zero pay
and when that doesn't work then some of
you are going to zero pay and when that
doesn't work we're
a bunch of us going to zero pay forever
and so if this thing
persists and so they people stayed
nobody took a pay cut nobody got
furloughed nobody got laid off as a
result of covet
but we did not know that at the time and
they appreciated just being told the
truth and treated like adults that's
exactly what happened
and other companies told them nothing
tell their employees nothing
nothing that's not leadership that's
doofus
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has
taken the place of the bmw as the status
symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality and host of the ken
coleman show
is my co-host today the ken coleman show
talks all about finding your purpose
all about your career getting a job the
income
side of the income out go equation that
i deal with every day
and ken's here to help you with that as
well as we will talk about your life and
your money whatever's going on
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five
alexandria is starting this hour in
atlanta hi alexandria how are you
hey dave hey ken how's it going great
what's up
um so i'm a 30 year old nurse
practitioner here in the atlanta georgia
area
um i spoke with you actually last year
in march um
and i followed your plan i was able to
eliminate 260 000
in eight months in debt whoa
wait a minute whole full stop way to go
and so you like took covet nursing and
made it like a thing huh
absolutely ding ding what did you make
in that
in this last year um
i owed 15 grand in texas so
probably i almost hit almost 500k last
year
whoa so how many hours a week were you
working um
so i worked seven days a week i worked
three different jobs when coveted i went
over
to new york and texas and i was making
10 grand a week up to 13 grand a week
doing that
and i just became intentional because
student loans were that i'm not
debt-free but they were interest-free
and i was just making sure i was
knocking it out i made a challenge to my
family that i would
eliminate those student loans by the end
of december and on december 31st i went
live on my social media showing everyone
that i paid off my student loans
freaking superwoman yes wonder woman
something i don't know that's amazing i
mean you didn't run hide from kovid you
went running into the fire
and stuff you told me i was being wimpy
last year so i
had a point to prove i called you
out and you went and did that i'm i'm
loving my advice right now
that's so cool coach put me in the game
i like it wow you are amazing girl i'm
so proud of you congratulations and
alexandria you're about to feel
you have to feel one lady said the other
day she said she felt accomplished you
have to feel accomplished
i feel very accomplished i sat down with
my financial advisor yesterday and he
said wow you're
you're really prepared and i was like
you know i followed the dave ramsey plan
and
thank you i feel really good for you to
say that to me that's very nice
i'm so proud of you okay so uh now
on to the next steps huh correct so i
have a six month fully funded emergency
fund
my max out all my 401k contributions i
maxed out at the 15
so what i did was i created an
additional ra for after tax
contributions
um but now i still have a good amount of
money left over from my salary monthly
and i just wanted to know what are some
additional ways that i could invest
i wanted to become invested in real
estate but i wanted to do it by cash
flowing i don't want to go back into
debt so
i wanted to know what are some other
ways that i could use my money to work
for me
and so i can actually fully fund and
cash flow real estate
wow that's amazing so your home is paid
off now
so i sold my home and i used some of
that money to
fund my emergency account because i took
a job in chicago so i'm back and forth
between atlanta and chicago
so i don't know if i want to buy a home
yet because i won't be in there for five
years so it wouldn't make sense for me
to buy a house and i'm not there for
five years
so that kind of leaves me where i am now
and i've already saved up a down payment
how many hours are you working now i'm
40 hours a week
okay all right wow well i'm glad you're
back to a reasonable rhythm now that you
had that year of craziness
wow so yeah so here's what i do i'm
trying to figure out how to apply it to
your situation when i max out everything
of course i'm in baby step seven which
you are right now because you don't own
a home so
um uh you know max out all retirement
that's available which is what you've
done and then i dropped money
into just an s p 500 fund
an index fund okay
low to no commissions and very stable
it's going to do exactly what the market
does
it is the standard for 500 dow jones
industrial average these are the
measures of what the stock market's
doing and so it's going to follow the
market
and that's what i do i park it there
until there's enough in that account to
buy the
piece of real estate that i'm wanting to
buy okay and i pay cash for it out of
that
and so it's gonna it's gonna be more
volatile obviously than a a cd or
something like that but it's also gonna
make about 10 times
more if it sits in there a year or more
too the increases
in value are taxed at the capital gains
rate which in your case is 15
um and instead of your ordinary income
rate which is probably 35
and so you get less taxes on it if it
sits in there a year on the growth
portion
and um you don't have any taxes on it
hardly because it's got
low turnover ratio until you pull it out
and so if it sits there three or four
years it's not going to create
taxes for you and um so
i i would i would tell you not to start
buying real estate until you've decided
which city just like you don't want to
buy a house until you decide which city
so
let's let's figure that out so this is
just a good place to park a pile of
money to buy your next house with cash
and then maybe buy your first rental or
two once you've decided which city
you're gonna settle into but you are a
beast girl
you're amazing absolutely incredible
yeah
again just you know she takes that that
statement that she made to her parents
you know her family
and she hit it i mean that is
there's gazelle intense and that's like
super gazelle now well i mean i call her
i call her wimpy and she's like i'm
gonna show you old man
which i love a good yeah you're right
she put the old chip on her shoulder
right yeah
wimpy this yeah it's the truth it's like
tom brady you know
six drop six round draft pick he's like
i'll show all you teams
i mean that is awesome and uh
he's amazing that what a great
seven days a week three jobs that
encourages me to call more people wimpy
i'm just saying
[Laughter]
who among us doesn't need a nice little
chip right
some people don't like the chip on the
shoulder i think a lot of great men and
women have done things with chips on
their shoulder
that i mean 500 000
as a nurse yeah in one year yeah
yeah oh unbelievable three jobs
i mean she went to texas she went where
the workers ran into the fire
that's what i liked she said right where
the money was the work was homework like
crazy
wow yeah extraordinary story that's uh
and paid off two hundred thousand
dollars worth of debt so i
and you know isn't it interesting how we
both live
someone listening to this who uh was a
nurse
and never left their home for 12-14
months
and their homes getting foreclosed on
because they lost their job at the
hospital
because they're not doing the elective
surgeries same exact industry
same exact economy same exact pandemic
and one goes and makes a half million
dollars another one loses their home
it's just that's just human nature is
amazing it really is you know we
you and rachel cruz and i we did this
big event
a message of hope and the big message
from all three of us was control the
controllables let me tell you something
alexandria said i can control this she
went after it
man wow
so impressive this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host i can't get over that last
caller making a half million dollars as
a nurse during covid
yeah i mean i'm just i'm all i can think
of is that
somebody will some people will always
find a way to succeed and some people
always find a way to fail
you know i mean people are going to look
back can you imagine like
30 years from now okay you look back on
9-1-1
okay or you look back on you know when
when your grandparents look back on
pearl harbor or we look back on 2020
with the
pandemic and you say and
and grandma's sitting there and she goes
best year of my life
yeah it's it's extraordinary because you
hear somebody make excuses about
how the pandemic ruined their life from
lack of opportunity okay and then you
hear alexandria's story and you go
huh why don't you talk to her yeah talk
to the guy in the plexiglass business he
did well
oh no nicole's with us in augusta
maine hey nicole how are you hi
i'm good thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
um so me and my husband are on baby
steps three i believe so we're
definitely the size of the house and
we're working towards our emergency fund
we have eight thousand in place right
now
great and after that thank you and after
that we want to buy a car
he got a situation to me and i've heard
you talk about it on the show
to stay away from it so i kind of just
wanted you to help me walk through the
situation
he says that we would like to save up
to lease a car so instead of paying
monthly you can just put it all down
in the beginning for the three years um
so he was looking at
a 2021 ram um with 380 a month
so that i'd be like 13 000 paying that
upfront
and then the buyout would be 2300 or 23
000 and in that three years of having it
saving up that 23
000 to pay it off um and i just wasn't
sure
how to go about that i've heard you talk
about leasing cars as the most expensive
way to drive
a car it is they just wanted your advice
it is and the most expensive car
ever is a brand new one the worst car
accidents happen on the showroom floor
so when he drives that beautiful
fabulous pickup off the showroom floor
he's gonna lose ten thousand dollars
that day
that's what i was um thinking because
his argument
was his argument is he wants a truck and
he's willing to
he's willing to overlook any amount of
mathematics in order to buy a truck
he thinks that he'll be actually getting
it for less
because it'd be 23. that's because he's
not good at math
and um and so let me help you with this
if you take 13 000 over to hertz
and prepay your rental payment they'll
let you drive a hertz car for a long
time too
and if you add up thirteen thousand
dollars and twenty four thousand dollars
and you figure out what you're actually
paying for this dodge ram when it's all
said and done
it is more than you would have paid for
it had you walked in there and laid
benjamin's on the table
because it wouldn't be until three years
later that it was i know
paid off listen let me ask you something
do you really think that chrysler is
stupid
no and that's why i was calling you
because i was like
your husband has not found the one time
that chrysler made a mistake
right like they've got to be making
money on this something
it's not like he found a loophole so he
didn't find a loophole when you add it
up
the actual cost on a lease averages 14
cost of capital it's like borrowing
money at 14
interest and the value of this car plus
this car is going to go down in value
rapidly because he's buying a brand new
car and you all aren't millionaires
no we're not so you should not be buying
a brand new car and taking that kind of
a hit and loss in value until you're
millionaires
you can't afford to lose this much so
boy's got boy's got truck fever he needs
cold showers what he needs
yeah and um so my other question when we
do go to buy a car
i know you say don't you know spin it on
or
buy it that's more than 50 of you or
your car is added together
oh all your all your cars added together
okay
that's good to know i didn't know that
and what is the annual income of both of
us yeah your household income what's
your what's your household income the
two of you added together
well right now i'm going to full-time
school so my income is very like hit or
miss
and um his is 70 000. and he is getting
a pay raise in september but only like
500
a month okay so he makes 76 000
and what are you know so you don't want
the all of your cars to be worth more
than about 35 40 000 bucks
and the only the only reason is is that
i love cars i don't know i'm not against
you having a decent car i'm against the
car owning you
if you've got 80 000 worth of cars and
you make 80 000 a year you have so much
tied up in things that are going
backward
that you can't build wealth definitely
yeah i was definitely hesitant on the
situation
but didn't really know how to
work it out to me you know to kind of
say okay this is a bad idea
um oh it's definitely a bad idea
so you start with the premise that
chrysler's not stupid and they're not
going to lose money
if you haven't figured out how they're
making money that doesn't mean they're
not
it just means you haven't figured it out
mm-hmm that's all it means because
listen
if you turn that car back in that car
has to sell for more than 24
000 at the time you turn it back in
they're gonna lose money
they don't lose money yeah they've got
thousands and thousands of dodge rams
on the road and they have lots of
statistical evidence of exactly what
that puppy's going to be worth at the
end of this lease
a closed-in lease the residual value the
buyout at the end of the lease
is is a statistical analysis it's an
actuarial table these guys do not screw
these things up
if they do they lose millions and
millions and millions of dollars because
it didn't just happen on your car it
happened on all of them like your car
yes so is the buyout based like
calculated to what they estimate it to
be in the three years
no the buyout is what they they estimate
it to be
more slightly more than the car is worth
oh okay at that time they're estimating
if
you got a twenty four thousand dollar
buyout at the end of the lease they're
estimating that car is gonna be worth
somewhat less than
twenty four thousand dollars okay yeah
that's what i was kind of thinking um
i think another person's argument and
the situation that we're talking about
was that somebody just bought like a
2018 like chevy for 35 40 000
in 2015 so they were like trucks really
hold their value
oh bullcrap you are
you are listening to a whole lot of
broke people with truck fever
uh listen i drove a raptor i didn't
drive it today i got a raptor in the
garage i drove it yesterday i
i like big trucks i i like you know i
don't own a single car with a horsepower
less than 400 horsepower
so um i like cars i like stuff that goes
with zoom zoom
but they all go down in value you're
getting screwed on all of them
financially when you buy them they're
all they all
suck this idea that you know they hold
their value
yeah just visit one that's three or four
years old and laugh about that stupid
butt statement
that's just ridiculous hold their value
by their fingernails for 20 seconds
maybe
yeah i mean look if people i've heard
this before i've heard people hit you
with these scenarios before it's like
they think they've got it figured out
well i mean i actually when i first got
on the radio there's a guy who's a
christian guy
in another part of town that called up
and he was all offended because he owned
one of the
car dealerships and i was telling people
leasing cars rip off
and they're ripping people off he goes
well i'm a christian i'm not ripping
people off and i'm going yeah you are
and he wanted to he went to come sit
down talk to me and after two hours of
going through the math with him
i said show me one time where you're not
making more money
leasing the car than you are selling the
car show me one time
and i'll shut up and he couldn't find a
single one well as christians we ought
to agree and i'm like oh christians
ought to be able to do math bubba
you know this is a thing you know it's
not it's not a christian thing i mean
jesus doesn't hate you
for leasing a car that's not the point
um
i mean i mean he probably yeah
yeah bad bad dad jokes are running
through my mind about being all in one
accord but anyway
yeah so yeah so yeah you just it's
but yeah it's just dumb it's just dumb
don't do it
you listen if you look around and you
don't see millionaires doing it
then that gives you a hint and if broke
people are giving you all your advice
about trucks holding their value
then that's another hint
[Music]
chrysler's not losing money that's
another hint
lots of hints here this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage
chris and jeanette are with us hey guys
hey dave how are you
better than i deserve welcome to
nashville
love the t-shirts be weird
hashtag debt free like it how much do
you guys pay off
we paid off 21 300 love it how long did
this take
about nine months good for you and your
range of income during that time
about 62 000 good for you what do you
all do for a living i'm in retail
management
and my wife stays at home with the boys
and she works at our local church
and children's children's ministry
awesome very good
good for you guys what kind of debt was
the 21 000 everything but student loans
i think
basically uh 401k loan credit cards
personal loans dumb spending yep so you
kind of have
you're like normal yeah you kind of been
bopping along look up
how long y'all been married 18 years
18 years yeah just go with it 18 years
[Laughter]
i've never seen that before with most of
it dialed in i'm telling you well we've
been
we've been together since high school so
we've been together for a while good for
you
okay so what in the world happened nine
months ago that made you decide we're
getting out of debt oh gosh so we have
we have to go back a little bit so about
12 years ago
we were young and dumb and we
went to go see a bankruptcy attorney
because we were ten thousand dollars in
debt
and the bankruptcy attorney looked at us
and said you guys are
not broke she's like um i'm gonna give
you a gift
and she gave us your book wow she gave
us your book what an unusual bankruptcy
attorney isn't that crazy most of them
will file bankruptcy on six hundred
dollars
and she didn't even cash the check that
we paid her
yeah so um i wish i could tell you that
we were like all right we're going to
we're going to do that
and but we did it you took the book home
we used it as a coaster
table yeah and then um last well
early 2020 um you came actually you came
out to our church real life
in carmel florida and you were there and
that
right after that we were like that's it
we're done we're gonna do this
so yeah well it was worth the trip it
was definitely worth the trip
i got one it was worth the trip
absolutely awesomeness now real life's a
great that's a great place yes yes you
got many folks yes
that's wonderful wonderful people and so
you come home from that and you're going
okay god just got in our face
we got to do this dave just talked at
the church yeah yes yep
and we were like all right we're going
to do it where's that stupid book
get the dust off of that thing and let's
get going we actually
did the fpu yeah so we did fpu right
after that
and um yeah just hit the ground running
wow yeah very cool congratulations
you're so good
how much did the community when you got
into fpu because you had heard the
message
from dave and he gives it right like no
one can give it you got
it yes then you jump in how did that
community of accountability
really strengthen you guys or maybe fire
you up even more what did it do for you
it i mean it did it totally did i felt
like
i was kind of always there it was him so
i thank you dave you
got to him for sure he has listened
hours and hours of just your podcast and
just
read your book and just he's really
dived deep in and so
wow yep i think yeah and we almost
didn't make it to the uh
to your um to your presentation at
church my wife was like no let's go
and i was just kind of she so she kind
of dragged me in and
man i think sometimes if i had never
gone you know we might be even more in
debt
so wow yeah it was just awesome it was
awesome wow so
yeah you know i i uh wow that's amazing
i'm just so proud of you guys it fired
us up
i even got a second job and everything
so i just got an email from your pastor
like two weeks ago oh
just checking in yeah he's such a great
guy he's awesome
so well done you guys so fun okay now
you've been through financial peace
university
yes you paid off 21 000 in debt
you're living on lesson you make
something congress can't do
and um what do you tell people the
secret to getting out of debt is
you're professionals you've done it yeah
um you said something that really
resonated with me when you came down and
you just uh you said god gives us the
dignity to
choose and you said just decide that
you're gonna do it and that just
stuck with me so when we got back home
we were like all right
we can keep doing what we're doing or we
can try something new and
we just decided and we were on the same
page um
i would say practice the practical
things for us was getting on a budget
we had done budgets before we just never
stuck to them and so now every month we
have a budget meeting before the month
starts and we sit down
and you know we we look at the you know
the monthly expenses and you know
the first couple months it was a flop
because we were you know but it got
easier and easier
so yeah you're not pros at at the first
little while yeah exactly a while to get
it dialed in yep
yeah absolutely but it can be done what
was
what was the toughest part for y'all
i got one the toughest part for me was
um
the saturday nights we we uh started my
second job
over uh delivering food yeah right
during cove my hours got cut in half
and i was like oh no we gotta figure out
something else so
i started ubering um food delivery
and so we just yeah the hardest part was
uh driving around on a saturday night
and watching everyone have dinner and
we're picking up deliveries and and we
kind of i was like man i would love to
just pull over and
go grab a bite to eat but uh we stayed
focused you know and we made our
car trip into a date night where we kind
of just you know we
packed the car with some snacks and we
hit the road and
you know that was a short time you were
like delivering temptation to every door
i mean
it really is that's harsh
it's like delivering pizzas when you
can't have any you know oh my gosh
it's hard what point in the nine months
was this moment that you just described
this was like really early on this was
um probably
march like during like right when
congratulations
yeah yeah march or quarantine city yeah
was there a point in the nine months
where you finally experienced momentum
you went okay i feel like now
okay what was it yeah uh for me it was
probably like um
like in the i think when we hit the
halfway mark we were like okay we can do
this
and so we started you start seeing those
numbers just keep going down
i sold one of my cars dave oh no i was
like we gotta get
we're i said we could we can go another
couple months or i could just sell the
car today
and we'll be done and so that's what i
did yeah knocked it out yeah
yeah and i'll show you up and get
another one yeah yeah yeah
so you brought the kiddos with you what
are their names and ages bring them into
the show yes
jacob and jaden jayden is here four
years old
jacob is my big guy he's 10. all right
very cool now who were your biggest
cheerleaders
um gosh our church family was awesome
our mother-in-law my mother-in-law she's
right off camera she did
wonderful things she babysat the kids
while we went out and
she was just cheering us on every single
step of the way so
that's huge to have family in there with
you and your church family yes
your church family as well yes well done
all right
chris and jeanette jacob and jaden from
orlando florida
21 000 paid off in
nine months making 62 a year we got a
copy of the legacy journey for you which
is the next step
in your journey as you move forward i'm
also going to give you an extra copy of
total money makeover
so you can pay it forward and give it to
somebody else and give them that book
that 12 years later they will read
that's so perfect count it down guys
let's hear a debt free scream
all right three two one
[Applause]
you know you and i log a lot of airline
miles or we did before
yeah and we will again yes uh every year
going to a lot of places and speaking to
a lot of people
and i speak to usually
in a typical year not last year but a
typical year 10 to 12 churches
as they're launching a church-wide
financial peace university initiative
and that's what was happening there in
orlando when i went down
and you know i don't always get to hear
that no that it was worth the trip
yes but that that made it worth the trip
always does
that's why everybody longs to work and
that's our work here at ramsey solutions
is to give
practical hope to people that you can
get where you want to go and that right
there that's that's real legacy
i love the book the legacy journey is
going to them because now they can
create
a legacy that they couldn't have before
because of financial freedom because
of financial peace this is the ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personalities my
co-host today our question of the day
comes from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee means even if you
mismeasure or you pick the wrong color
they'll remake your window blinds for
free free samples free shipping
and the new promos they run all the time
you save even more use the promo code
ramsey
it's magic it'll get you the best deal
today's question comes from karen in
alabama she asked
my employer is secretly interviewing for
my position to hire someone else in
at a lower salary should i stay until i
get let go or start looking for a new
job now
karen start looking now
if this i mean we have to assume this is
true this is not good this is
horrible leadership i i'm not laughing
because i fee
it's this is so bad that an employer
would do this
and uh uh uh i don't know
and they're not even good at it no she
found out
right yeah it's time you need to look at
your employer and say you're fired
yeah that's exactly right how about i
fire you
yeah i'm gonna secretly leave right now
oh
wow yeah you need to go get a job
yesterday kiddo
that place as fast as you can run don't
walk
heather is with us heather is in raleigh
north carolina hey heather what's up
hey oh my gosh thank you gentlemen for
taking my call it's such an honor to
speak to both of you today
you too how can we help um
so um i have actually instead of gone
backwards in pay i was able to
double my income in this past year wow
um
yeah i'd finally you know make the six
figure mark which i had
a lifelong goal of hitting before i hit
35 and finally hit that at 36
but for you what do you do thank you so
much
um i am a medical scientist for clinical
research
so i looked at clinical trial data thank
you
thank you so much um but with that comes
some challenges that i'm trying to face
and i'm hoping to get some advice
so i'm married we've been married for
about nine years we have two small kids
and my husband still wants to keep
everything
separate and i'm trying to get us you
know
out of debt um i currently have
a nice you know student loan chunk of 92
000
and some personal stuff that i'm trying
to get rid of um
but he just doesn't want to get on board
and instead wants to keep it separate so
i have absolutely no idea
what's going on on his end of things so
i'm wondering can i do
this um baby step number two by myself
now that i have my bigger shovel
or you know how can i get my husband on
board because
now that i make essentially double what
he does he's having a hard time with it
so i don't know how to handle it
why am i not shocked um
what does he do for a living oh he's
military
okay all right yeah uh what does he do
in the military
um he is um he's active duty so
yeah yeah he's active duty in the
okay army right uh just infantry is that
what you're saying or he doesn't have a
specialty inside the military
uh no he's uh special forces okay all
right good
yeah yeah so he does a lot of stressful
high intense
stuff and yeah
um yeah
this is a marriage problem this is a
marriage problem it's a marriage problem
it's not a financial problem
and um uh and
uh the chances of this guy that you
described to me going to a marriage
counselor is probably fairly low
um but that's what you guys need you
need someone to
help you navigate your pastor at your
church could serve the purpose if he's
he or she's got some counseling shops
but to sit down with someone to help you
guys navigate through
all the different variables that are
happening in your relationship you
making more
his uh incredible intense job
what it is that's causing him to want to
keep the money separate
why does it need to be separate what's
he afraid
uh of i've made some you know bad money
decisions which
racked up some debt but i'm working
through that you know i just paid off my
car
two years early uh this weekend how long
ago did you make bad money decisions
um so uh
let's see i guess since we've been kind
of been dating i'm a big impulse
spender i mean how long ago was your
last bad
money decision um over a year over a
year ago
yeah okay all right so maybe part of you
all
combining this is for you to be
accountable
yeah which i'm totally fine with you
know that's kind of why i want him on
board like i want to be held accountable
i want him to say hey do you really need
that trip to target you know
200 toothpaste well we have a budget
that we have agreed to before our month
begins
and it would include target only to a
certain amount
and anything past that you would be
breaking your contract with him
yeah which i'm fine doing yeah yeah is
he very conservative with his money does
he have any debt
uh he does have some debt he just bought
a new truck last year
and i know he's got a credit card but
he's been a lot better with money he had
a bunch better
money school than i did growing up um
but i mean other than those two things
that i know about i don't know
about the other stuff all right you know
i see stuff come in and
let me tell you here's the day the data
points are this okay
um that
get guys and gals that do what he does
they face death in the eye fairly
regularly
and so they have a tendency to detach
it's a it's a normal defense mechanism
um
and uh it's very very tough
to be the spouse of special forces
um until they really get their arms
around
uh all the emotions that they feel
and plug those into your relationship
it's a very tough thing we do a lot of
work with special forces i
i think these are some of the best
people on the planet they're incredible
but
they do things and see things that none
of the rest of us
can do or ever see and so
it just is a different world and um
but that doesn't change the data the
data tells us that couples
who do not work together on money have a
higher
uh problem rate in their marriage and a
higher divorce rate
and have a lower chance of actually
building wealth
the do it separately and be roommates
thing almost
never works relationally or financially
and so he's barking up the wrong tree
it's not gonna work
it's bad tactics for the mission would
be the phrase i would use to him
okay the tactics that he has laid out
for this particular mission
suck the mission's gonna fail and the
mission is life
and marriage and wealth building and the
tactic that he's using
is a defense mechanism it is not
a it's not an offensive proper tactic
that's how i would talk to him and you
can play this back for him if you want
to i don't care
because i love the guy i love what he
does i love what that i love that i'm
free because of men
like him and so yeah so am i
yeah absolutely yeah i'm you know i
appreciate him
but i don't appreciate the way he's
treating his wife
and i uh and you gotta your your part in
this is you're gonna have to stop the
stupid stuff
and you're gonna step into the
accountability and use your newfound
income and if you can get him to the
table your newfound cooperation to
really make some serious strides forward
so
we're going to help we're going to
salute you in your new
uh promotion and we're going to salute
him
because we appreciate what he does for
this country we're going to give you
ramsey plus for a year which puts the
two of you into
uh financial peace university together
every dollar budgeting app together
and uh if you guys will watch those
videos together
and start i think it will cause him to
come to the table possibly
and start doing these things together
i'm challenging him to do that
um you know i need him to man up here as
as and walk with his wife not just throw
her in the ditch and hope she makes it
you know you did something stupid like
for a while and i don't trust you so you
just
wallow over there in the ditch by
yourself good luck with that
you know that's just not that's not
manning up and so
um you know walk with your wife for
richer for poorer
in sickness and in health until the all
my worldly goods
i pledge those are the old-fashioned
marriage vows hold on kelly's going to
pick up
or get you signed up to go through
ramsey plus together but i also
recommend you sit down and see a
marriage counselor while you're doing
that too
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show you can listen to all our
shows with the ramsay network app on
your smartphone
browse by topic or even sync clips to
your friends
download the ramsay network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
host of the ken coleman show ramsey
personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five
listen tonight is the get hired event
tuesday the 27th of april ken coleman
will be doing a live stream event
teaching you the seven step path
to your dream job the seven things you
need to do to get to your dream
job get hired this economy is heating
back up after covid
the competition is picking up for the
jobs and people are stepping out
and it's time to get into a position of
something that you love
and ken can help you do that it's only
thirty dollars for the live stream
text the word hired to three three seven
eight nine
it starts in a matter of about four
hours
from right now seven central eight
eastern text hired two three three
seven eight nine get you a thirty dollar
ticket and get hired it's gonna be
awesome gonna be a lot of fun dave live
crowd in our gorgeous lobby here at
ramsey solutions world headquarters
and of course people tuning in wherever
they have a device
and a internet signal so it's gonna be a
lot of fun we're gonna give you the edge
to win tonight don't forget uh you're
trying to convince employers that
you can help them win and if they're
looking at multiple people it is a
competition i don't care if you want to
look at it that way or not
that's the fact we're teaching how to
win yeah and there's there are some
things you do
to get hired that's exactly right
there's a strategy involved these are
practical steps this isn't
mindset this is i've got to do this
so that i get the opportunity to be
interviewed and when i get interviewed
how do i win that interview
and this is for those of you that have
realized that filling out one
application
among 10 000 people is not working for
you oh yeah
yeah the days of going on linkedin and
firing 50 resumes and sitting back and
waiting for the
waiting for the results are long since
over you're now getting ai
artificial intelligence is looking at
keywords in your resume most of the time
you're not even getting a human to look
at it initially that's if you're lucky
if you're lucky you're right you may
just get buried in a pile we'll have
about 30
000 applications come in this year for
300 grand we're going to hire 300 people
this year and we'll have about 30 000
applications we don't have ai
that's true and that simply means you
are going to be stuck in the pile
if you don't do something to get your
resume out of that stinking pile yeah
and ken can show you how to do that for
ramsey he can show you i do that for a
lot of people
and uh and so uh you know there
is a series of common sense steps here
that he's going to walk you through
so text uh text hired
to 33 789 text hired two three three
seven eight nine emma is with us in
dallas to start off this hour hey emma
how are you
hi thank you so much for taking my call
i'm great how are you
better than i deserve how can we help
my husband and i are currently on baby
step number two
we need to buy a second car though so
that way i can go back to work in office
i have been working from home since
covid and they're now wanting us to go
back
so we need to get a second car okay we
have ten thousand dollars in savings
right now so my question is should we
put our saving
towards our debt or buying a used car
oh so you're not really in baby step two
you're working your own plan
well i'm trying to be in baby step two
i'm just trying to figure it out
maybe step one is what what is baby step
one
saving a thousand dollars and everything
above that goes on your debt
right so you didn't do that
well we just got married so the ten
thousand dollars came from
when did you get married in february
okay yeah and this is april
right we're just you gotta decide you're
gonna have to decide what you're gonna
do here okay
so what would i do i'd go buy a two
thousand dollar car
i would put uh seven thousand dollars on
my debt and i have a thousand dollars in
the account
and i would do that by friday are you
going to do that
sure absolutely i mean i just want to
make sure that
i'm doing the right thing about the used
car i don't want to um
buy something brand new either and i
also have a 20 you can't buy anything
brand new for 2 000
i'm sorry you can't buy anything brand
new for 2 000 you don't have that
problem
oh i know i know i'm saying that i have
a car loan
that has 23 000 on it so i'm wondering
if i should trade in my car
also at the same time oh you
okay that's a different part of the
question that i didn't know anything
about until just now
you said you needed to go buy a car and
you had ten thousand dollars we need two
cars
and you have one of them's 23. so the 23
000
car is that the loan amount or is that
what it's worth
that's the loan amount what's the car
worth
um from kelly blue book around 25.
so it's worth more than you owe on it
yeah
and what's your household income about
45
000 dollars between the both of us yeah
you need to sell that car you don't need
a twenty three thousand dollar car when
you make forty
you have too much tied up in car twenty
five thousand dollar car so yeah sell
that car and oh there's the two thousand
dollars you can
buy a car for two thousand dollars when
you sell that car and have 2 000
extra in your pocket after you pay the
loan off right
right oh wait a minute we got about two
cars now but you get two two two
thousand dollar cars
okay so you get one you know go buy two
two thousand two
two through two to go buy two cars that
are worth anywhere from two to three
thousand dollars out of this scenario
and put the rest of it down to a
thousand on debt
and you're driving a couple of beaters
now your rule of thumb is
you do not want to own vehicles that
equal more than half your annual income
all your vehicles added together because
vehicles go down in value
all of them and you if you have too much
tied up and things going down in value
you can't win
okay gotcha so i'm gonna get into two
three thousand dollar cars how much debt
do you have
uh sixty five thousand total twenty
three that is car loans and forty two
thousand as
student debt okay and then i'm going to
plow through these student loans when
the student loans are gone i'm gonna
build my emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses
i'm immediately following that gonna
save and move
up in both cars and get you a couple of
cars that when you add the
value of the two cars together after all
this is done
it's still not more than half your
annual income and you pay cash for them
okay that sounds great so you're going
to drive you're going to drive these two
cars that are worth two or three
thousand dollars for
about two to three years is what it
sounds like to me
that's about how long you're going to
drive them but not for the rest of your
life just for a period of time
to be able to get yourself dialed in
here so hey thank you for calling
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five so when you give the
seven steps to the the seven path
seven things you need to do the path to
your dream job tonight
those are in order yes you must just
like anything else think of it as a
climb
and so we've got to get to this stage if
you will
and then once we're there then we're
prepared we're moving on to the next
they all work together i must get clear
first
so that i know exactly the type of work
that i really want to do
and then i can say what does it take to
get qualified then i must get qualified
before i even get the chance
to actually do the work and i'm getting
connected while i'm getting qualified
because i can actually
while i'm getting prepared i can be
making connections so that when i'm
ready
doors are open and they're in order
always in order
baby steps are in order over in
financial peace too kind of works that
way
that's why they call it number two it
comes after number one
this is the ramsey show
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs and the ability to
negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau
chm is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
if you're thinking about buying a home
this year here's a simple piece of
advice that could keep you from making a
six-figure mistake don't buy something
you don't understand
and in this current home environment
this is not a uh
this is not amateur hour uh when houses
are selling for more than they're listed
for and there's multiple offers
putting your home on the market with an
amateur is a bad idea
buying a home right now through an
amateur is a
bad idea start by checking out our new
13
step home buying checklist and you can
learn about every step in the buying
process
and you can be connected to one of our
real estate elps text
home checklist no spaces
home checklist to 33789 and we'll send
you the free
13-step home buying checklist home
checklist
233-789 lauren's with us in richmond
virginia hi lauren welcome to the ramsey
show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call god bless you i love what you do
thank you love what you do how can we
help
um we are a happy happily married couple
25 years um just about to be empty
nesters
um and we feel like we have missed the
financial boat
uh so to speak we um we started out
ready to invest around uh 2001 when the
tech crash happened
and so we didn't invest in the stock
market and things like that because
we're
concerned we just saved up enough money
and we're getting ready to invest when
the 2008 real estate crash
happened and again we pulled back and
did not invest so we just stayed put and
we just kept saving
and now all we hear is cash is trash and
the american dollar is in trouble um
and we don't we feel like we have missed
the boat and we're concerned
now that maybe we missed a way to help
us retire
how much do you have in savings
uh two million dollars
okay i'm i'm absolutely amazed
and so all of this money is just money
you put in there because you've never
really made any money on your money
no we've hardly made any we have self
ladder cds and done some bonds but
basically your rates of return have
sucked and you still put to got to two
million dollars
and and you're still afraid
to invest yes okay but you have two
million dollars
so how did you miss the boat
how big a boat were you wanting to get
on i was gonna say that's a great boat
okay but we're just we don't know now
that our kids
stuff has been paid for college and
things like that we just
never took any time to do anything or
plan for us
as much as just keep our head down and
work hard and
now we picked our head up but what vote
did you miss you missed out
on a bunch of returns that you could
have had four
or six million instead of two million
but you still have two million dollars
so i don't think we can really cry a
river here
okay but when you say four or six
million that makes me
really sad but i there's no way to fix
the power no all you can do is think
about the future
okay so okay uh let me pare it back to
you what you said to me
every time you got up the courage to
invest
you found a negative story somewhere
that caused you
to not do it fear yes
yes and now your new fear is the
american dollar is going to pot
that's your latest one yes that's your
latest one yes
and have you noticed that your other two
fears didn't come true
yes i don't like roller coasters maybe
that's the problem yeah but the roller
coaster
even even with the roller coaster it you
wouldn't have lost all your money
you would not have been broken homeless
uh that the 2008 real estate crash
actually had
almost i mean in the stock market crash
it came back and
you know it went all the way down to 6
300 and it's a 30 000
a day and so you know you missed out on
all of that yeah it's a ride but you
know you're going to either
uh not have you know if you had ridden
the roller coaster
you you know you might have had eight
million dollars
yep and so even if the roller coaster
screws
up it's got to really screw up to be to
en
to end up with nothing you follow yes
and so i don't think that i i personally
am not of the belief that america is
coming to an end she's got her problems
we have a whole truckload of idiots on
in both sides of the aisle
in uh dc and thank god it is not up to
them
it's up to people like you and me out
here that get actually get things
done as to how this nation runs and
whether this nation works and whether we
learn to treat each other with some
respect out here
uh and so you know this all this
craziness on the news cycle is just out
of
it's just nutty everywhere so but all of
that said
i don't think that well i'm 60 i'm older
than you
and i have 100 of my retirement in
mutual funds and a whole bunch of our
wealth
more than that in uh
in real estate that i paid cash for
because i think in both cases they are
going to go up in value dramatically
more than cds will go up
now are they going to go straight up no
they go up and they go down and they go
up and they go down
and can you stand the ride so let me
give you an exercise or two okay
because here's the thing okay there's
two kinds of fear there's fear that
keeps you from touching a hot stove or
playing in traffic
because those things will get you hurt
that's good fear
it protects you the other fear is false
evidence appearing real
and that's the fear you've been
operating on and i know that because for
instance
if you will pull up just go visit with
one of our smartvestor pros and ask them
to show you some examples don't
buy anything just go over there and
start to learn
ask them to show you examples of during
these very volatile times
what did mutual fund a mutual fund be
and mutual funds c do
and follow what they did and say okay
had i invested in that
through what i feel like were very
turbulent times i don't like roller
coasters
quote here's the roller coaster ride i
would have signed up for
i think you perceive it to be the
world's tallest coaster
and you're going to go oh that's kind of
like the kiddie park
when you actually look at the actual
history
and the actual math listen i don't like
starting over i went broke i don't want
to start over
so i'm not investing in stuff that's
high risk either
i you know i don't i don't like extreme
volatility i don't like
high risk i don't personally invest in
any of those kinds of things
so i don't have money in bitcoin i don't
play the roulette wheel in vegas
i don't run up a bunch of debt trying to
make money i i do
very low risk stuff and so i think you
need to learn
about the historical data
on some actual real mutual funds and you
will be amazed at how
much less the risk was than your
emotions are perceiving it
and i think that'll help set you free
because here's the deal
you're gonna be fine you've got two
million dollars you're gonna be fine
congratulations you're amazing
that's what's an amazing task that
you've accomplished but if you keep in
mind this
if it's invested at ten percent rate of
return instead of one
it's going to double every seven years
so when you're 64
you're gonna have go two to four to
eight
oh and when you're 71 it's 16.
if it's at one percent it's not even
going to go up a million dollars between
now and 74.
71. so you're either gonna have 2
million or 16 million
between now and early 70s depending on
how much you're willing to
learn and if you learn to drive a car
then driving a car is not scary
but otherwise they make loud noises and
people honk the horns on them and the t
the wheels screech and they're really
scary until you learn how to drive them
so i'm never gonna learn how to drive a
car that's false evidence appearing real
any closing thoughts i think it's
absolutely well
because it was just a fascinating study
in psychology there
and these are people that are so
disciplined and they're the ones that
are worried about doing something stupid
i i would just say to her i don't think
you guys
could possibly do anything dumb if you
go do your homework and actually learn
about it
by the very nature of what they've been
able to amass with sheer
discipline it was amazing i mean their
money their money didn't work for them
they put all that 2 million in there
you're not gonna do anything dumb at all
yeah the chances of you doing something
extremely stupid are very very low
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us america the get
hired event is in just
a couple of hours at 7 00 p.m central 8
pm eastern tonight it's a live stream
with ken
coleman text the word hired to 33
789 for your 30 ticket and you will
learn the steps to get hired
emily is with us emily is in boulder
colorado hi emily how are you
hi good how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
so i have a couple questions um i'm
actually headed to
sell my car right now so i'm gonna try
to make it as quick as i can
maybe get to the second one but the
first one
um sorry my voice is shaking so much um
the first question is my boyfriend and i
were currently living
in his mother's basement and
we are we were planning to have enough
money saved up to
be able to move into an apartment in
july
however with the relationship to his
mother
she's now wanting us out sooner
she's generously offered to pay for us
to
do so but um because of the relationship
dynamic uh i'm
just a little unsure whether or not to
take her up on her offer so one option
is for her to just pay the first couple
months rent
and the other option that she suggested
was to
for her to buy a property
and us to essentially pay the mortgage
or to
basically rent to own
okay um
how old are you i am 30 and my boyfriend
is
27. okay so you're my kid's age
um and so i'm gonna pretend like
um you and i know each other better than
we do
and that i care deeply about your future
okay and um
uh because i do actually care deeply
about your future but we don't you and i
don't know each other that well
you've listened to me on the radio and
i've talked to you for a minute and a
half
all the time but um we listen to you
every day religiously
yeah and so if you've listened a lot
you probably have come across the call
where i tell people not to buy
properties or rent properties with
people they're not married to
have you heard that before yes
so it would not come as a surprise to
you that i would suggest to you that
this is ludicrous
it's about it it's a bad idea the one
where the one where she buys a house
and and wants you to be involved in
buying it with her son and you're not
married to him
is like about one of the craziest
dumbest things you could possibly ever
sign up for
please god don't do that
okay okay there's so many things wrong
in this transaction legally
relationally financially yeah there's
just
there's this is all dumb please don't do
that
and these are good people trying to do a
good thing a bad way
sure so um
yeah if she wants her son to move out of
her basement
and she wants to help him get an
apartment is she just going to give him
some money to do that
yeah she's um i haven't been involved in
any other conversations but basically
what i've
what i understand is that she has a
certain amount of money that she was
willing to give us for an apartment
uh we did find one but we uh
we were going over the lease agreement
and just
realized that it was a really bad
decision uh there was
like pretty much all the liability was
on us so we backed out of it last minute
which is now why they are both
considering
this other option
you just didn't find an apartment yet
and you know okay here's what i would
suggest you do
okay and and i i
i i know i'm asking a
real hard turn from where you guys plans
are so i don't know how successful i'll
be and what i'm asking
but my motivation is pure and my
uh experience is um 30 years of talking
to people like you
okay so he should go get an apartment in
his name
period and if his mommy wants to give
him some money to get out of her
basement
that's between him and her you should
not be on the lease
with someone that you're not married to
and you certainly shouldn't be in a rent
to own
with someone you're not married to yeah
if you choose to shack up with him and
move in
to his apartment that the lease is in
his name
that's certainly your choice i would
recommend against that but i doubt i'm
gonna get that far
if i can get if i can get you far enough
that you're at least not signed on
documents with the guy you're not
married to
uh we're at least making some headway
for protecting you
okay because if y'all break up no let me
try this
when you break up
and you're both on the lease you know
how hard
this is going to be legally because the
apartment complex is not going to let
either one of you off
somebody's going to be in there not
paying it and the other one's getting
screwed
yep please don't be on a lease with
someone you're not married to
please do not buy a house from his
mother
on a lent to own with someone you're not
married to
you set yourself up legally not only
relationally
and we can talk about morally and
spiritually if you want to but i mean
all of these other things you're just
setting yourself up for all kinds of
problems honey
and i just i want you to win
yeah it was a little scary to to me but
i just wanted to
hear that from somebody else because
we've been getting conflicting advice
from
his parents and my parents and i know
ultimately it doesn't matter
does what i'm saying makes sense to you
yeah it no it definitely does okay i'll
just add this very quickly dave gave you
a really great dad perspective
and and i'm just going to tell you if i
had your boyfriend on the line
you've mentioned twice that there's some
tension i'm just
that's me kind of pulling that out but
there's a relationship issue already
between
him and his mother i wouldn't take the
mom's money he needs to be a big boy
he's 27.
put his big boy pants on and he needs to
go get an apartment and i'll tell you
what else if i had him on the line
he needs to commit to you i think dave
dave said it
very well i'm not adding to i'm simply
saying
i wouldn't i wouldn't enter into any of
this unless you're unless you know this
guy's committed to you
you guys are playing house right now
you're 30 years
old i don't know dave i just wouldn't
take the money from the mom it feels
like that could be
if there's an unhealthy relationship
with my mom or my dad i don't want to
take money from him
you're talking to him i would tell him
that that's what i'm saying i'm talking
to her right now i'm just trying to get
her away for this
oh i agree um you know illegally away
from it
into a lease with this crazy situation
dangerous
so um but yeah i mean
and emily you just gotta understand i
mean ken and i are uh we're considered
old-fashioned dinosaurs
in our in our viewpoints on these things
but and i
so i'm only coming at you from the legal
perspective that you're going to get
trapped into a lease
when his mom blows your relationship up
and you'll be trapped in a lease with
mama's boy and um
or or a young man that's at war with his
mother
who's a control freak i don't know
what's about to come up but this is not
gonna go well
this is not gonna you know there's
they're having this is this is
there's issues here and so please please
please give yourself
uh escape routes uh don't don't chain
yourself to someone that you're not
married to uh this is your roommate
argue over whose mustard it is
don't argue over things that are gonna
bankrupt you
uh or put you into a situation that
takes you five years to recover from
this landlord suing you
because the two of you broke up and both
of you moved out and nobody paid the
rent and you ended up paying it because
he disappeared
and his mommy's money with him and so
this is just
danger danger danger danger red flags
all over the place
and that's what i would tell my daughter
except i would take it a step or two
further
than i did with you uh in terms of um
other paradigms through which we would
look at it as well
uh that we just ran out of time and
can't get to
but please don't do this this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today hebrews 12 11 no
discipline seems
pleasant at the time but painful later
on however it produces a harvest of
righteousness
and peace for those who have been
trained by it
c.s lewis says hardships often prepare
ordinary people for
extraordinary destiny
love it open phones this hour ken
coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host this
hour ryan
is with us ryan's in san antonio texas
hey ryan how are you
hey dave thank you thanks for having me
on the show
sure um hey another question for you
guys
um my wife and i he's been following
your program for years now
we've we've made it all the way through
baby steps three
paid off quite a large amount of debt
and uh earlier this year um
our house worked down
we uh we just uh
anyways we're still going through the
process now you know and with insurance
and all that
and we actually just um
we finished uh just last week we
we had to access our uh six months
emergency fund
um to help cover some costs and all that
but we actually just topped it off again
so we're so we're back we finished baby
step three
and now we're on the four five and six
and we have a budget and we we've fallen
we're following your steps and doing all
that
the the issue is that you know with
insurance and you know with all of our
contents and everything you know
at some point we're going to come into a
you know
sort of a large amount of money that to
cover all these things that we lost
and honestly we you know we don't know
what to do we're so used to just not
having money
and and you know budgeting and saving
all this and then
when the settlement comes and we get
that money
we're a little confused about what to do
with it
okay well it is earmarked for two things
one is to rebuild the house and two is
to refurnish it
yes and i mean we have one policy
which is covered for uh rebuilding the
house and that's sort of taken care of
and then we have a separate
policy for all of our uh to refurbish it
um and uh
i mean you know i don't know what that's
going to be
and i and we're so um
i don't know the word is thrifty that uh
you know i
you know i i'm not it could be tens of
thousands of dollars i'm not sure
but you know once we rebuild it and we
have leftover money
or once we refurbish it's like you know
what do we do when you rebuild it and
you have all the furniture in it if
there's any money left then worry about
it then
i mean should it go to
i don't know four or five babies at four
five and six yeah
yeah it'd be five and six if you have
money left
after you refurnish it you need to take
this money uh and
you know you've got the building project
itself which is one lump of money
you've got the money to replace your
personal loss your personal items and
furniture
and that's a different check am i
correct
correct that needs to go into a separate
checking account
and you need to manage the refurnishing
and replacement of your items
as a separate project completely
independent of anything else
okay so just treat that money completely
separate from
anything else until you get the house
completed
and you move in it and you're done and
you go
okay we're done oh look there's five
thousand dollars left
oh look uh we had to put money into this
because we didn't have enough oh look
you know whatever but you're gonna
manage it to swear
i'd like for you to rebuild i'd like for
you to refurnish the home
and have a little bit of money left if
you refurnish the home buy your clothes
buy the blender whatever it is you got
to buy
and uh and there's a bunch of money left
that's fine but i don't most of the time
you're not going to get enough to
actually come out of this with a profit
so i think it's more emotional ken to
set this aside and manage it as a
separate project yeah
look ryan you're a smart guy you
understand the baby steps you've got
this down pat you guys are very thrifty
using your words when dave says worry
about it when it happens
worry but there's nothing to worry about
you'll know what to do
uh i just again there's this fear that
you sense over you
that you're gonna do something wild or
crazy with it and i don't even think
that's possible
so trust in yourself you got this yeah i
think you can do it
it's so emotionally devastating to have
a home to lose your home
because it's so much of your life goes
up in those flames
oftentimes and um and it's just
it's it's on the list of things
that'll put you in the hospital like the
loss of a child a divorce a death of a
loved one the
uh a bankruptcy other catastrophic
personal events uh
they come into play here and you've got
one
of the big ones you know and that's what
you're facing so
uh you know emotionally process that
and um but i i think you give yourself
permission to
not make money but not go into further
in the hole because of this
if you came out and had zero if it was a
sum total zero can
and the home is refurnished and the home
is rebuilt and there's not a dime left
but you didn't put any of other dimes in
other than insurance money
that's a complete win absolutely it is
because
like you said this is a traumatic
situation i mean
you know just to kind of reset because
you can't replace
yeah you just can't it feels like it's a
lot of money but it's probably not
i think that's what i'm saying yeah i
think that's probably right when you get
down into it when you start listing out
and you go okay we gotta buy couch
we gotta buy a rug yeah you gotta buy a
lamp you gotta buy these two tvs
you gotta buy blender and you start
putting dollar amounts beside those that
money's gonna go pretty fast yeah even
at a thrifty rate
it's still gonna add up even being
intentional and careful and managing it
as a project and not being helped or
skelter with it you're still
got to be careful yeah alexa is with us
alexa's in denver hi alexa how are you
hi i'm good how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
yeah i have a question i'd like some
input from you guys on
so i am at a job right now
i guess you could say overall
comfortable really good pay
really good benefits the you know the
atmosphere or
the environment is good i feel
appreciated you know everything wow the
only reason i bring it up
is because i am a mom of three kiddos
um so it's a little harsh on the family
and i
i guess i'm going into about six months
in this job right now
and i guess i'm starting to miss my old
jobs working with kids um
i have kind of a really office job right
now um
but you know as i mentioned i'm overall
comfortable
um the schedule is a little tough on my
kiddos i work for
ten um so yeah i guess i'd like some
input
from you guys so you're you used to work
with children in your old job
yeah so my my most re i guess i've
always worked with children um
but my most recent was at a school uh
working with
kindergarten through eighth grade
students and now and now what do you do
i'm a court clerk okay all right yeah so
your heart your heart's going you got
two things going on in your heart number
one
it's tough on the kiddos and you're
feeling some uh maybe some mom guilt or
you're going this
i can't keep this up this is tough on
the kids so you're starting to think
exit anyway
and then thinking about that exits got
you thinking about what do i want to
enter into and i think you're coming to
the realization
i really love working with kiddos does
that sound about right
i mean i think so yeah so here's the
deal so you got to take care of those
kiddos
so i'm i'm fine i think if you're asking
hey is it okay to be looking
yes i don't want you leaping i want you
looking hey if i know
that the work i want to do is with
children then let's look at all the
different ways that
you can work with kids and you've
actually got a background you've got
some experience and some skill set there
and i would be looking to make that
transition don't feel guilty
about wanting to leave a job that for
all intents and purposes
is a good comfortable job but if you
know you're supposed to be doing
something else you need to embrace that
and start to take the steps to move
towards that but be smart about it yeah
what would be the
parameters that would be the dream job
yes
and the hours who you're interacting
with
what you'd be doing and so forth yeah
yeah
that and if you lay that out then you'll
know when you find it
if you if you itemize it ken good hour
thank you sir
james childs kelly daniels thank you for
the show today great job as always i'm
dave ramsey your host we'll be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace
and that's to walk daily with the prince
of peace christ jesus
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
you